[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long
time what if i started doing that what
if i tried to introduce that i've gotten
it in a few different places i mean why
are we still talking about this intro
it's old news now
no but i almost changed it if there's
something freeing about just
letting something just go do you can do
it in your party you can't change it
until you've established just i mean
we've messed with it so much
sometime in the as you explain what
we're talking to talk about just hold
out a vowel
holding out a vowel is brings health and
vitality and who are you
i'm red this week
at the round table of dim lighting oh
and i'm link
see you messed me up yeah yeah unless we
say it was all a test
this week at the round table the dim
lighting we're talking about
what are we talking about we're going to
be answering uh some questions
you know we've been talking about a lot
of things about trips and
preparation for trips and we've been you
know arguing about things
she's going to shoot the breeze we're
gonna just talk about some things that i
mean it may get heavy
you know you never know it may get heavy
that's what we should have said it
should
welcome to air biscuits it may get heavy
but it's
but the the general disposition is that
it'll be light is that it's light we
come in light
very light but then things start getting
a little saturated
and we get heavy i have uh
got to give an update on my medical
condition okay i'm just getting heavy
right from that
i suffered an injury i tangled with
wildlife and uh
messed up my face i saw this yesterday
for
for a number of days on a video check i
actually started to get
scared christy confessed last night as
we were going to sleep she was like you
know i got a little scared that
you were never going to be the same
that your face was going to look like
that forever yeah she was like
i you might have to wear a mask when we
make love i was gonna think about that
and i was like yeah i could wear a mask
of what my face used to look like
this is the conversation we had last
night while falling asleep and i think
that's the moment i fell asleep i was
like
yeah i would just wear a mask of my own
face of what it used to be that raises
some interesting questions that we can
discuss a little bit later like
our mask work i've never done any mask
work no i mean
that's what you're asking not to make it
uh serious
unless it's not to make it heavy really
but like
there it happens quite often not quite
often but it isn't
uncommon for like one of the people in
the
relationship to undergo some sort of
transformation like sometimes it can be
extreme like the woman who had her face
torn up by a chimpanzee
gosh no i'm saying for real and then she
had to get a face transplant
so i i guess what i'm saying is is that
i don't know if she was in a
relationship at the time
but like to think that and i know i'm
not throwing chris
i'm not throwing christy under the bus i
know she was probably joking but uh
you know i don't think you can yeah i
don't think she was joking to put on a
mask
she was joking i think it's to find the
acceptance in the new in the new
the new face yes of course i mean yeah i
wasn't
i didn't take it personally and i mean i
immediately fell asleep i was not con
i didn't take it to mean anything while
you had a run-in with wildlife it was
not nearly as serious as
running with a chimp it was it was uh
not to minimize it
but i did notice it on our video call
though
i know you did and that was that was
many hours later
just okay so let me let me tell the
story
so i went mountain biking
on uh saturday morning and
we're we're near the end of our ride and
well first of all
we're like trucking up this this
i'll call it a mountain more like hills
but a lot of uphill
like work at work at work and then
finally you get to the top and then you
got a lot of downhill on these
single tracks and some of it was quite
sandy
and um nick who i go with he's
he's he's faster than me so i don't i
never like to go
in front when we're going downhill i
always let him go first
go at his own pace i don't want him
breathing down my neck and forcing me to
go faster than i want to go
you got his new fancy bike yet he got
his new fancy bike he's got even faster
he's going even faster
he's got dual suspension and i still got
the hard tail
so my butts i just don't think i can
ever get taking a beating man i i'm just
too i'm too worried
not about what happened to you but i'm
just worried about well
add this to the list so i'm coming down
the single track
and i took a wrong turn and then i
finally caught
i got back on the trail and caught up
with nick who was waiting for me
and then to finish out the run i went
ahead of him and like two minutes of
going ahead of him just trying to get
the end of the
end of the run taken care of i'm going
faster than i actually want to go
because like just subconsciously i don't
want to be like
the chump that's slowing somebody down
and i hit this sand patch
and my wheel turns to the left my bike
keeps going straight
yeah and there's this moment where
everything slows down
and you're like well am i going to fight
this or am i just going to
am i going to fall in the most
controlled way possible
which i i elected to do you fell oh yeah
i went
i went off of the bike in front of the
bike that's why i'm not going i hit the
ground
and did like a stuntman roll and then
back in my mind
and you don't have on like pads or
anything no he was sandy
i could have hit a rock but not with my
head but with my shoulder or something
yeah it could
i did a stuntman roll and part of it was
not to injure myself and part of it was
to
kind of look cool and purposeful because
i knew i was being watched by nick who
was coming up behind me
you know and not that he gives a crap or
that i give a crap that i fell off the
bike
or you know it's but still
subconsciously you you don't want to
look or when you're falling you gotta
you gotta you've gotta learn into
something you gotta turn it into
something
so then i'm like i'm like i'm fine i get
right back on the bike and
i let him go first and then we get down
and we
we exit off the single track and we're
on this fire road going
the rest away the exit out we're going
pretty fast but we're
it's no longer treacherous territory so
my guard's down
and that's when i get hit in the
forehead with a bug of some sort
and i'm like dang that kind of that one
that was that was a hard bug kind of i
mean
like a windshield exoskeleton and um
then i realized i feel a crawliness
happening like under my sunglasses in
between my eyebrows
so i instinctively what kind of
sunglasses you got like
bike sunglasses i i have these like
nascar prescription
uh sunk sports sunglasses they
fit tight they're oakleys and they look
really stupid but you know what they're
like nascar but they're
the best but they're really light and
they from practical
from a practical scene that's why i got
them they're so like
i hate that like they became associated
with it with a certain well they're yeah
they're
i think they're the best glasses i wish
i could make them look good because
when you put on like cool sunglasses
they let too much light in the sides and
you can't really see
you put on those oakleys that are like
nah i'm going to a nascar race
like you can see every night they're not
the most aggressive tint either so i can
wear them
and slowly in lower light because i need
them for the prescription don't hurt
your face
and i'd rather not wear my normal
glasses like i'm wearing right now
you know they don't protect you from
what you're about to tell us yeah so
it's like
i feel the crawliness and i'm still i'm
still trucking down the road
and so i just grabbed the the arm of the
glass of the sunglasses
and i just yank them off my face and
then like
throw them down behind me like i don't
throw the glasses down but i like
i try to how would you describe that for
the listeners
uh just kind of just kind of jerk jar
them off
jar the jar the insect off sling
but so i fling it yeah i fling the
glasses in order to get the thing off
and then
i'd i flung pretty aggressively and i'm
still pedaling pretty aggressively and
then i just
slam my glasses back on my face and
i got stung by a bee
right right in between my eyes like not
in between my eyebrows
right in between my eyes right there did
it not on the bridge of my mind i lost
your mind to
inspect the glasses like you flung
but then just i flunked so hard i there
was no way
i thought there's no way this bee or bug
or whatever it was
can hold on to anything like that well
yeah they can't
look at me oh he's still there but i
should i'll do that next time i'll do
that next time because let me tell you
it hurt
and it was i was like i just got stung
by a bee i was like
oh [ __ ] and then i like stopped you know
that bee died for you
he thought he was protecting his colony
or something his colonies are like
300 yards behind oh yes point and it i
mean i knew i got stung it did hurt but
it didn't hurt that bad but then
a few seconds went by and it started
hurting
a lot more face is a bad place to get
stung i mean it could have stung me
right on the eyelid or the eyeball
that eyeball it could have if it was
crawling right in front of the lens when
i slammed it back on my face
my eyes open you would have closed your
eye i bet you it could happen but i
think it's pretty unlikely you you would
have gotten out
what happens if you get stung in the eye
and the ball and the ball of the eye
i don't think an eyeball can switch
probably doesn't even hurt
yeah it's probably awesome probably
can't even feel it probably makes you
see better probably like man what is
that i can i see a fuzzy bee
really up close it's stuck permanently
to my eyeball until i
blink it off the pain
spikes after a few seconds as it turns
out and then it
sent an immediate headache across the
whole
that whole the whole stratus of my head
where's the last time you got stung by a
bee
it's hard to remember right when you had
a bee beard
i think that was it yeah when we when we
did the 50
000 bees all over my face and then after
you blew them off with a leaf blower
one of them was clinging to my neck
it was ten thousand but fifty thousand
does sound bad let's say fifty thousand
and it probably wasn't ten thousand but
that's good
uh and now that one didn't hurt that bad
on my neck yeah next not a bad
face it's like a glancing also that was
a different b
uh those those were juvenile calm
bees and i think they probably i don't
know maybe they don't have as big of a
stinger this one was
so wild man an aggressive could have
been a killer bee so i'm like well let's
get to
one of those murder hornets that's
around no just like an africanized bee
so um i was like well let's just get
back to the car before my whole
face swells up but by the time i got
back to the car which was like
maybe 15 minutes later you were on your
way back
yeah anyway yeah if you had been on your
way out would you have
turned around and going back home no
okay
uh because i just i'm not allergic to
bees it's not that
big of a deal you know uh
but then by the time i got back the pain
was subsiding
i was like okay fine now the thing i
didn't do that i wish i would have done
was
inspected to see if there was a stinger
and then like try to
like scrape it out with my fingernail or
something just to make sure if it
that it wasn't still in there and then
eat it like i did when they took the
stinger out of my brother when i was a
kid i don't know why
it's like a ceremonial rite of passage
he's just sitting there watching my
parents take it out they put it on a
paper towel
and it's like i'm gonna eat that and i
ate it it's so weird i i
like i just not i know i eat everything
but it's just such a weird
choice yeah that's that is weird i'll
eat the stinger
and then like what happened to it and i
was like i was embarrassed i was like oh
i ate it
you were embarrassed i don't know why
it was super impulsive wow that's
strange
i'm not i'm i don't do that many things
like that
i don't just eat things that aren't
edible unless i'm being paid
it's been starving it's been absolutely
it wasn't for hunger it it was so
strange i think maybe i thought it would
be like a honeysuckle or something
is that what the honey comes out of it's
like eating a honey nozzle you wanted to
suckle the honey
the honey maker i think maybe i took it
and was like i'm gonna suck the honey
out of it and then i just ended up
eating it
i know that's not how honey works okay i
know honey but i was like five
i'm gonna suck the honey
there's gonna be some venom there's
gotta be some residual honey
no it's venom i know it's a completely
different part of the body
i mean it's when a bee stings you it's
not injecting you
know the honey is just it comes from the
stomach and they spit it out oh
man honey is b vomit the other end of
the bee and they don't die when they
give it to you so i drove home i told
the family the story i didn't think much
about it
um you know that was i mean like nine
o'clock in the morning
that evening was just you know it's just
a normal saturday
that night i stayed up till like 1am
wasn't i i started to notice that like
there was a red line when i would take
my glasses off
but i just thought my glasses had been
on my face you know i just wasn't
concerned
and i going to bed that late i was
planning on sleeping late but then
i woke up at like 6 30 in the morning
kind of frustrated but like even before
my eyes were totally open
i could tell that like out of the bottom
of my periphery like you're laying down
and you're kind of looking
you know trying to see what time it is
without opening your eyes all the way
i noticed that all i could see was flesh
you can see here when you can see
yourself you know something's up
yeah i was like you could see your own
face and then i immediately got
i immediately got scared and i didn't
want to wake up christy because i didn't
want us
i didn't want to scare her um
but i i went downstairs and i went to
the bathroom
and i i mean that's the that's the first
picture i took
and that's in the morning that was in
that morning so
and it gets it got worse than that
right but like i tried to i tried to
take like a video where like you could
really see
that it was what is the redness on the
the redness on
the right side of my the bridge of my
nose is where it stung me
and then it's just that redness is just
swelling
and then it's it's starting to swell 90
like
the the nut the eye gap
you know the the flesh on the bridge of
your nose in between your eyes but
like below your eyebrows whatever you i
call that the eye gap
that started it started to really swell
up
and then my cheeks started to swell up
right under my eye
as well and then it doesn't so much
later on that day i tried you know it
kept swelling
and i took a selfie because i was gonna
i was gonna send it to nick and tell him
like remember that bee sting and then
i took that one and i was like nah i'm
gonna take one where i smile
because i don't want to look miserable
that doesn't look like a smile that was
a smile
are you allergic to me talking about
beastie well the funny thing is is it
doesn't it doesn't
strike me because of the way it's so
perfectly
symmetrical it doesn't strike me
as you with an injury it strikes me as a
different person who actually
with a f of this like a fat nose
like bridge it's not and when i put on
my glasses it covers most of it
up so you really can't look at almost
the same i look kind of normal
but i was i was kind of scared and i
looked it up and i was like
you know is this gonna is this gonna
close my airway am i to have a major
allergic reaction
not a day later yeah not a day later it
was what they call a moderate reaction
which is
i wasn't having any hives or any other
any any reaction anywhere else except
right where it stung me
and then i felt better when i read for
the mayo clinic
that you know it will be 24 to 48 hours
of swelling before it goes away
and of course this is now the third day
and it's i'm looking pretty normal again
right but
no this is what's today tuesday yeah you
know it's interesting because
um i i was
already under the impression that and we
talked about this before that you look
different without glasses than you used
to look without glasses
yeah that like you wearing glasses for
an extended period of time
has done a very very slight something to
the bridge of your nose
has it that makes you but now i don't
know if it's just i'm seeing the
residual bee sting
but i thought i've thought that for
years that like whenever i
started wearing glasses in like 2005 or
six or something like that yeah
and then like seven or eight it's
morphed my face
into it i was like oh link looks a
little bit different than he used to
look
i mean you also had aged eight or nine
years but like
it i did can that happen is my nose
bridge starting to slouch because of
it's not slouching is just glass slight
is very
slightly wider wider
what's lighter right here no no no it
ain't wider man that's from the bee
sting
well no that's what i'm saying for right
now that's what it is i
it's just it's definitely the beast
thing right now because it's not all the
way down
when you take your glasses off i'm like
that doesn't look like link without
glasses that looks like a very slightly
different person
yeah and it's like kind of like my dad
too
my dad doesn't wear glasses i'm starting
to look more like my dad
but when i came home i mean when the
kids woke up
they couldn't they couldn't look at me
they were like so freaked out that like
dad you look like a different person and
lily was like
you look like like
in the movie avatar when like the guy
goes under and then he
he becomes his avatar and they kind of
it looks like the guy
except the like the space in between his
eyes is
bigger yeah because they almost make
their eyes look like cat like
what happens on a cat's face right here
yeah yeah a little bit wider that
fat nose bridge and yeah i got the
avatar
i don't know it's not as much well it's
not that much right now we did our
uh you know once a month we did like a
company-wide
zoom call and uh link was a little bit
more swollen yesterday and he was
telling the story and he like showed
himself
and then emily said that he looked like
the baby man mask that i wear that you
wore
and then i guess the first time you were
because it's got a white
it's got a wide nose bridge too yeah and
it was like yeah that's exactly what it
looks like
yeah so i mean i'm sure that
chrissy would be fine sorting mail with
me in the long term but in the short
term
she he she was joking but i mean there's
some truth in the joke
that like maybe maybe i need a mask
like i need to make a mask if when my
face goes back to totally normal i need
to
go ahead and make a mask of it it could
also be a
something that we give away to the
mythical society we could give away like
well you know they make those like hyper
realistic old people halloween masks of
us they're like you know they're like
made of like silicon or something
silicone
whatever the correct word is for that
and then they uh
the way they fit around the eyes is like
really perfect yeah like i wonder how
much it cost to get one of those
made like that would be crazy
to get very creepy but
kind of cool how come and i'm sure this
does exist
doesn't that exist don't they make like
that
old man mask that you see people wear
and it really legitimately seems to
transform them into an old man
why are there celebrities that you can
just become or is that a bad idea
because then people will just become
those celebrities and do heinous things
it doesn't look that real i mean
one of these things are you talking
about like mission impossible like tom
cruise ripping off
just recently on twitter i saw
a dude just put one of the old man masks
on and like put it pull his collar up
above the thing
and it's just like you have to glue
around the eyes no it's it's fitted
to his eyes i think oh really and so and
of course
the old person thing works because their
eyes are a little bit
you know more sunken and like fleshy
around there anyway so like you just see
like an extra fold and you don't really
oh think about what it is
yeah and maybe we should maybe we should
have all these messages old man versions
of red and lake
no we're becoming old men yeah so let's
just get the masks made now
mythical.com we'll merge it up
so i'm feeling i'm feeling relief that
this morning
a the air quality was better you know
the at least the fire it was weird
though according to yesterday morning it
smelled like smoke in the morning yep
but this
air quality it looked fine
there's like three different things this
morning was great and my nose was normal
ish
sometimes it's smoky sometimes it's ashy
and sometimes it just smells like smoke
but it's clear
i don't understand today was the first
time it was like totally
in the green it seemed normal and i've
you know what i i appreciated for the
first time i was like
i'm walking around i'm in los angeles
but i'm actually
i'm free to breathe for once you know
it's the little things
once they're taken away because the
whole place is burning
so i'm feeling good i'm feeling like i'm
glad you're okay
i'm back to my i'm back to my norm back
to myself
of course then i get in here and i'm
waiting for you to get here and i'm i'm
trying to do something my computer and i
my day gets ruined again i don't know if
well we can talk about that if you want
to but
i don't know if you want me to go if you
can withstand some negativity
oh would you what your yo well let's see
well first
we might come we might come back to that
if it naturally
occurs we are going to answer some of
your questions uh
but first we're going to remind you that
we have
uh grooming products we we stay
relatively well groomed
speak you know i mean i speaking of
chimpanzees think about how much i care
about my face that's all i've talked
about for the past 15 minutes yeah
so if you're in here about your face
your face and your hair and your skin
and your
we've got things that can make that your
beard better for you your beard your
lips your hair
grooming and if you want the things that
we have now
we will not have them forever right in
the current state
that they're in and some things may be
going away forever so i'm just
we're just giving you this the subtle
warning that like
if you're if you're into the grooming
products and you want
you want to make sure that you that you
have some of these for posterity
and maybe some of it which is just
because you really like the pack
the current packaging then i would say
gobble it up mythical.com
um i will note that i'm
i'm wearing the shirt that you wore of
mine
on the podcast a couple of episodes ago
your shirt that became my shirt
and i just wanted to demonstrate that i
wasn't wearing your shirt when i was
wearing it
in my mind it was my shirt you had given
it to me but here's the thing
i have and then you took it back i have
given you some shirts because
some some shirts are like borderline too
small for me and then they get washed
and then they become too small right
but because i have a precedent there's a
little bit of a precedent of doing that
sometimes my shirts get put
into your area i'm i know you didn't
give me the shirt now
right but i did think you gave me the
shirt then but this shirt is not i mean
this shirt is not too small so you know
and now that i don't know how i ever
wore that shirt now that i see it it's
all i mean it's almost too big for me it
fits you just right
yeah i i i was actually experimenting
with wearing larger shirts
and now i'm done with that oh that one's
i mean is this a larger
that one is larger i mean we both went
through a tight shirt phase
but i'm going back your tight shirt
phase
yeah was so too much did you see did you
see the rock
yeah so yeah what was up with that
tightness
well he like you know he he he did his
like endorsement of biden and harris
uh famously independently political
the rock came out in support of biden
and in the video
he had on half a shirt he was some of
the things people have said about
this shirt and like how he gets it on
it's like
i i think it was uh eddie from you know
gus and eddie
uh he like tweeted
breaking dwayne the rock johnson
endorses
the tightest shirt of all time which
just struck me as
yeah it was a bit strange but the um
he almost looks like the grapes from
fruit of the loom you're like like his
his
muscles his pecs and his everything is
so developed
and it was like so tight and then
somebody observed
how does he wear a shirt this tight and
you can't see even a hint of his nipples
oh really i was like man you can't see
the nipples and he's like
it's a video i think because he he puts
um
tape his nipples his tape over i think
he just has
really small soft nipples he might have
had him removed surgically
for that reason for the smoothness of
his tight shirts
smoothness and tightness but when you
see a dude that's that
muscular wearing a tight shirt you kind
of just like okay first of all
i get it you know you've got those
muscles might as well show them off
also i assume that it's hard to find a
shirt that
like imagine imagine the rock in a shirt
that fits
like the one that you have on right now
like how big would the shirt have to be
to like have this like extra in the
sleeve like i mean
he would look ridiculous but then
but if you go back to like i don't know
what year it was i mean
what do you think was peak tightness i
mean i got pretty tight but you got
extra tight what was
peak tightness like two thousand what
the thing is
twenty fourteen i don't know
i'd like to develop some sort of excuse
or rationale as to how it happened it
wasn't
and it was the style i think it was also
i would get really attached to shirts
and then they would be they would shrink
but i would really like the shirt and
then i would keep wearing it i have a
built-in
uh sort of because i i have a very
attached
i have a built-in buffer for that
because if the shirt gets tighter it
also gets shorter and then it's
so yeah then it gets where i'm just like
you can see my belly when i reach for
things and i'm like
so that doesn't happen i don't even have
the you know i don't have the option i
got to get
long shirts i get long shirts wash them
and then they become normal shirts for
me
this is an extra long shirt which i'm
surprised is why you wore it
i feel supported in a tighter shirt i
prefer
sleeping in a tighter shirt because i
feel snuggled
really yeah yeah so it actually makes me
feel more secure
it's like a dog in one of those security
blanket things where you like
when you cinch a dog up with something
on it like a back like a baby in a
and a burrito wrap that's like me i
didn't do it for any but i didn't do it
for the looks like they just feel like
you're in the womb yeah yeah interesting
or in the loving arms of
my my mother i mean maybe your mom had a
much tighter uterus than my mom
i don't care to comment on the tightness
of our mother's uterine
man that is that's messed up man i
i just how big of a baby were you
you know there's no if i i wasn't that
big if i put a gun to your head and i
wouldn't do that but if i were to do
that and i would say if you
if you can't tell me how much you
weighed as a baby i'm gonna
i'm gonna kill you i'm gonna sting you
with a b this is just a gun that has a b
on the end and i'm gonna sting you on
the face
uh i'd say i was seven pounds six ounces
with confidence put the gun away really
i don't know yeah i don't know either
seven something
yeah i would just go for something
believable uh
let's answer some questions uh these are
questions that we liked
that you asked a while ago that we never
got to
uh first one comes from michelle the
velvet hook
oh here we are long time mythical beast
she's got a picture of uh
me you you're in an upper right hand my
nose and beard is in it uh but we've got
participation patricia arquette
patricia this is uh after the golden
globes
we did not go to the golden globes but
we went to a golden globes after party
which we talked about
on your biscuits right and we've done
that several times we've gone to after
parties
even wearing tuxedos and it makes you
seem like you went to the
awards but you didn't because you
couldn't get into the awards but you
could get into the after party i believe
this was
just it's a pr tactic this was the first
and last party that we attended
wearing tuxedos which we now own because
they said
don't rent the tuxedo you should just
buy it that way you'll have one whenever
you need one again and i've never
worn it again well because i mean
happened i mean
no one's wearing well this is golden
globes 20 2019
this is like january this is a long time
ago
but the question is i'm forever
wondering what happened at the golden
globes after party last year that led to
link neal holding
patricia i don't know why i can't say
your name arquette's award
y'all never said anything about it when
you talk about the party on your
biscuits please tell us
does this does this moment that's
captured here does it
i mean i'm firmly gripping and looking
down at her award
she's making eye contact with me and
starting to grab the award
does it look like she's trying to take
it back or that she's finishing handing
it to me
what is she looking at might be looking
at you she's looking a little
i think she's making eye contact with me
i think she is too
it's a little too high for you yeah
she's looking at me
she's like why aren't you grabbing my
award that's not what she's thinking her
husband's right beside her don't make
this
stranger than it is i don't know if
that's her husband uh i do
you do yeah because i remember that i
met the guy
and i'm i just got that vibe that it
wasn't like
it wasn't a handler it wasn't like an
agent or like a
a professional person this is a personal
person
and the other reason is because here's
how this happened
this is what i do remember yeah um
a girl came up to us like a teenager
yep and she was a fan
and she was like oh my gosh she's so
cool seeing you guys here i'm
i'm i'm a mythical beast and then she
ended up saying
i'm patricia arquette's daughter
and then was it in the same moment that
then she walked
up or i think it i think then she was
like sorry i gotta go
and then she like followed her mom and i
think her dad
somewhere else this is the whole family
right here that is uh harlow is the
daughter okay
shout out to harlow mythical beast um
but then we were mingling quite a name
harlow olivia
how do you say that just you know you
need to you need to preserve her privacy
man
she's a celebrity's daughter man yeah
but she's not a celebrity
she's i think she's a she's uh she is i
think she's a an
actor okay so
we're mingling around this party the
best that i can recall
we like say hello to her again and then
we started talking to like
patricia was talking to a lot of people
i mean when you've won
she won the golden globe for uh
best performance by an actress in a tv
movie or miniseries for
escape at denamora
which was um the true story of a
of a of a woman who worked at a prison
helping two guys escape
seems pretty cool never saw it directed
by ben stiller
you know a lot about that um well i had
to look it up because i couldn't
remember any of it and um
she gave an acceptance speech like a lot
of it was bleeped because she was
talking about her
her janked up fake teeth and her janked
up real teeth
and i get and then she was using the
f-bomb
a lot but she's a very spirited person
and she always
she when she wins a lot of stuff because
she's super talented and she has
she has these famous speeches where she
like takes a stand on
issues i'm up here i'm going to take
advantage and and
so people she's always the talk of the
town the next day so even that night
after she won
and had given this memorable speech i
believe about voting actually
um voting in 2020 ironically enough
voting in 2018. know this is 2019.
uh so she was way ahead of the game on
that and so a lot of people are trying
to talk to her and get a little time
with her but like we had an
end because of her daughter and then she
turns around and
i don't remember what happened but i'm
sure we said something
that made sense or at least you did and
then i'm like
like congratulations or something and
i'm pretty sure i was just like
gotta hold it can i hold it yeah i mean
how often do you get a chance to hold a
golden globe well i think our only
opportunity is probably going to be
then at the at the after party when we
asked someone who won one right i'm like
can i hold it
and it's like i wonder if anybody else
asked her that
or does anyone ask anybody that it's i
mean
it's a little it kind of comes full
circle though
you know what i'm saying because romano
gets embarrassed for falling off of his
bike in front of his friend who doesn't
give a [ __ ]
i don't think i don't know why i think
you get embarrassed by much
yeah i wasn't um i
i think that the um
i held it look i'm holding it right
there the instinct
the instinct to ask if you can hold it
which i completely relate to and
understand it's sort of based in
you know being from harnett county right
it's
because because we're just a couple when
you boil it all down we're just a couple
of guys who grew up in harnett county
yeah who the idea of a golden globe is
like
can i hold it yeah you know what i'm
saying because it's foreign i mean by
definition
it is foreign and so uh but then the
difference between me and you
is i'll think that and wonder and think
but
i don't want to necessarily just reveal
that i'm from harnett county
and then you're like well i don't care
but the interesting thing is what i'm
saying when it comes full circle is that
by actually going full circle
and asking if you can hold it i don't
think that
patricia arquette thinks that oh this
guy is a redneck
i think she's just like oh this guy just
he wants to hold the golden globe
patricia
the realest of the reason i'm gonna hand
it to him and i'm like if you
you know you might as well just check
all pretension at the door when you're
interacting with uh miss arquette
she grazes a little she was like sure
but the thing that and i held it and i
think i said
something about how heavy it is of
course that's the only thing you can say
yeah because what else
it's kind of like being a celebrity and
saying yeah you're shorter than i
thought you were right right
right right and what are you gonna say
this is like much much lighter it must
be hollow this is
this is cheap is this the real one yeah
right uh no it was heavy
one of the things we talked about this
before that we've learned about these
after parties is
streamies are not that heavy the
photographer you know there's people
going around taking pictures
and like you want to create these
moments that's why we one time we
we faked a fight at the gq party or
wherever it was
and we got a picture taken um but
the uh look on my face is that what
you're gonna talk about
no i'm just saying that that's a dumb
look you holding
the golden globe i'm staring at it
it you could think oh sh this must be
someone that she
really knows and is connected to because
she's letting him hold
you know what i'm saying like you don't
it kind of looks like she's trying to
story
this guy who's that guy did he win one
right so i'm saying that
doing these kinds of things is
ultimately a good thing because you will
get good photos taken
yeah i had i have many people
congratulate me on on my golden globe
that's not true uh let's ask another
question
so we cleared that one up shell
long time coming but we did it one iron
but the rumors to rest
one iron four this doesn't keep me up at
night i think because we asked you guys
does there anything that keeps you up at
night
but uh that
when we sleep we just see the back of
our eyelids like our eyes don't
turn off or anything it's just covering
them like sunglasses the way you just
read that
seemed like you were just reading it to
yourself can you read it again in a way
that
makes sense to me uh well it's not
really phrased as a question
it's just it's a statement when we sleep
we just see the back of our eyelids like
our eyes don't turn off or anything it's
just covering them like sunglasses
i know what's up here for the longest
time i thought whenever i would
sleep or even just close my eyes i
honestly thought
i'll say as a child okay that my eyes
were holding back in my head
i thought that like as the shades came
down the eyes rolled back you mean like
a baby doll
yeah like if you lay one of those baby
dolls down
in that that is what happens their
eyelids are weighted so they come out
there there's a there's a weight on the
back of a baby doll some baby doll's
eyelid so that when you turn it like
that
it swivels but the eyeball the eyeball
stays the same on the back
yeah i thought the eyeball rolled back
in the head and then
can you feel what that feels like though
because then when you open it
i guess they when you open your eyes
after being closed for a while
it kind of has a sensation of them
rolling back well they might go back a
little bit
that ain't true but they move around a
lot during rem
but no but what one iron four is talking
about is what you see
so early on and
when i was a child and i and i don't
return to this as much anymore or
think about it but like i just noticed
that when i close my eyes if i really
stopped
and focused i could
lock into basically a light show
that has the sensation that i am like
traveling through space
and seeing stars pass by me like a bunch
of little dots right
and the way to enhance this is if you
just take your eyes
and you press on them and it will
enhance that effect
and then also and then it doesn't hurt
your eyes no i'm just
pressing very lightly but then there it
is okay now i've made i i have focused
on
this like membrane
does this not happen to you uh no
but i think you haven't focused on it i
haven't i think there's
you have to see something i i i looked
up an explanation for it and when i read
the explanation
i was like i've never experienced this
and it is what you described so let me
read the explanation and then i'll try
it
um the huffington post article
uh you close your eyes and right before
you fall asleep you notice something a
twinkling a swirling pattern of stars
and colors producing a makeshift
light show on the inside of your closed
eyelids
that's what you're describing many
people who have seen this visual
phenomenon think it is a
light induced after image of what they
had seen before they closed their eyes
which is not i mean if you stare at a
light or something brightening close
your eyes
you still see an after image that does
happen but that's not at all what i'm
talking about
and and disagrees but an after image may
only be part of what they are seeing the
real reason
we are treated to this fuzzy fireworks
display behind closed lids has to do
with
phosphines p-h-o-s-p-h-e-n-e-s
phosphines are the moving visual
sensations of stars and patterns we see
when we close our eyes
they're thought to be caused by the
inherent electrical charges the retina
produces
even when it is in its resting state so
it's like you're looking at
a wire that has electricity going
through it essentially
so see i just closed my eyes and i feel
like i'm seeing
i'm definitely seeing some after images
we got some like strong light sources
uh you got you cover your eyes with
gently
impress press on your eyeballs gently
man i've still got swelling
no and then okay and then you have to
stop and then there is like a
it's very difficult to acknowledge it
but once you acknowledge it
and focus on it you can actually follow
like the fabric of space-time that
you're seeing
inside your eyes it takes sometimes it's
really really easy and obvious
but hold on okay there it is i'm locked
in again
and i can literally see like this
it's like stars but they're super
tightly packed stars
and they're very very faint and they
do they move yes it's like constantly
moving like you're moving
through them it's very hard
to finally focus on and see but i did it
as a kid and ever since then i've been
able to do it
i i can't i can't seem to do it yeah i
think you just have to like
i think you just need some time alone
and a lot of time you know just a lot of
time
a lot you need a lot of time alone
because it's you know what it is
it's the same exact sensation
it's a totally different principle but
it's the same sensation of staring at
one of those weird things in the mall
and all of a sudden seeing it oh it was
there all along but i had to like cross
my eyes a little bit like that's how it
feels
shannon is strange you talking about
that weird guy who always sit in front
of mrs fields cookies and like
make you not want to get a cookie
because he was like why is he always on
that bench you know i'm talking weird
the things yeah you look at what you see
what are the hidden images
we put one in the book of mythicality
can't remember what it's called did it
work though
uh did the how would the book of myth
academy work no once we decided that we
didn't have the capability to create one
we made it a joke
that on the next page we revealed that
there was nothing there right
because it's because it's not easy to
create one
like we thought oh we did not want to
spend the money surely there's a company
but it's not as easy as you think well
sometimes if you're just
with your eyes open if you're staring
like if you're just like
relaxing and then your eyes just kind of
you like your eyes are open but you're
not really using them
see floaters you can start to see
floaters and it's like you're seeing
things
on the surface of your eyeball looking
at moving around looking at a
clear blue sky like i mean yeah funny
thing is
as a kid i already had floaters i guess
i've got more now
but i don't sit around and look at them
anymore but like as a kid
i would just look at the sky and then i
would start following the floaters and i
would try to like
move my eye right not too fast i can do
that
you know that's a totally different
thing because you it'll it'll start
drifting and that's really your eye
drifting i think because then when you
try to focus on it it moves back
i think that it's slowly moving across
the surface of your eye because
your eye is wet but then if you focus on
it
it will move with your eye it will move
yeah and that that's why you
when you can start to feel like it's on
there but i highly recommend the the
phosphines just
closed eye visualization
okay it's gonna get a little heavier
let's get a little bit let's get a
little heavier okay yeah let's do it
um swain michael swain
what is the achilles heel of the human
race we always talk about
finding the achilles heel to aliens if
they came for war
to defeat them what is ours and can we
do anything to bolster him
what is the achilles heel of the human
race i think because
my mind is still in this uh
largely in the same place it was when we
recorded
the last episode which i know kind of
ended on a downer when i
started talking about how we're
hopelessly divided
as a country and uh i have this hopeless
feeling
it's been weighing on me i think as we
get closer to the election and so by the
time this comes out we're
barreling down on these two links yeah
so
and who knows what will happen between
talking about this
and being that much closer but the
rhetoric
and the the heated dialogue and the
people
getting into their trenches it is so
pronounced right now and so
so i've been thinking about this like um
and just one thought i have i don't
think that i'm not going to say this is
the achilles heel but i think one of the
things that has happened
because i've also been thinking i've
been thinking about like longer term
more global things and like
you know it's one thing to talk about
the impending demise of democracy in the
united states
which let's say potential uh i'd like to
have some hope
well i'm just saying yeah the
potentially impending demise i'm not
saying it's definitely gonna happen
but again when you think about the the
united states i mean we're still talking
about
if you think about all of human history
we're still talking about a very small
period of time that the united states
has been around it's not going to be
around forever
right what worked a generation
ago might not work now like but if you
think about
like the human race and the history of
just us as a species and our future
which i think is kind of the
sort of the 50 000 foot view that
michael swain is talking about like the
whole human race
so i i think that a big issue is that
our
technological evolution has outpaced our
moral evolution so you're talking social
dilemma
well i it to me it's when i watch
research it's bigger than the social
dilemma but yeah the social dilemma is
is like a symptom of it but i guess
ultimately i'm saying is like
just from a just a general like almost a
mathematical
logical equation we've developed the
ability to destroy
ourselves before we've developed the
collective
will to protect each other
and so if we don't continue to evolve
morally to a place where
you know empathy wins
versus sort of this self-absorbed
um group mentality yep it ain't gonna
it's gonna it will end as we know it
civilization will end
i'm not saying that the human race will
go extinct
well i mean what we what we understand
human
civilization to be will not last
unless unless those things balance out
not that we have to just talk about the
social dilemma
the documentary connecting the dots that
i was
i was already i felt like i was aware of
but it was like
it was it was a nice packaging of it
of just connecting the dots between how
the information is served up to you is
so customized
for you that it's not it's not about
truth it's about whatever you will click
on and that
we are the we are the commodity our
eyeballs are the commodities that are
being sold
to advertising it felt weird
to be you know in our business to be in
the business we're in that we're
creating content
that then um you know we attract certain
eyeballs and then people buy that
you know even on this show so it's like
i i don't want to
i don't want to that's a whole different
book that's a whole different
conversation but
you know just just being struck with the
reality
of how divisive
uh how cus
how customization leads to division
you know when everything's just for me
and everything's pres
everything is presented to each person
whatever they will respond to the most
not what is the most truthful or the
correct thing then you get in these
bubbles where
if you google it that's i the things
that stand out for me is like if you
google
climate change is depending on who you
are
and what what google knows about you
and you you where where you are
who you are you're the more information
they can get
the more that they're gonna it's gonna
fill that in with something that you are
going to respond to
not something that's going to give you
facts because global warming is a hoax
right or global global warming is
um is true you know the thing that that
was
just one to me again like you said like
i think everybody
has a little bit of a sense of this that
this is the polarizing effects of like
your facebook feed in your news feed
but the google thing was was striking
because you
you start seeing that like oh yeah this
algorithm which is
the algorithm is not programmed with
truth in mind
right it isn't it isn't fact checking
itself it's just like
my goal is to keep you user
on the on the computer connected online
as long as possible to expose you to as
much advertising as possible
so it's definitely like one of the
things that happens is
you know some people are super super
fear-based and so they're gonna just
any news that is telling them about all
the [ __ ] that's going down somewhere and
how things are getting really really bad
like
they're addicted to that type of
information that kind of doomsday
situation and so they're going to click
on those kinds of things
and you're like oh crap it's like how
have i been
they're going to get this if you're if
you're scared you're gonna
you're gonna if you feed off of fear
then you're gonna they're gonna you're
gonna be fed more of
more fear if you're fed off of outrage
or anger you're gonna be fed that
on either side you're gonna be pushed to
an extreme because
that's what we we respond to extremely
and the crazy thing is if you're scared
of something
being told that you shouldn't be scared
of something is not a strategic
way to for for an algorithm to
you don't want to assuage the fears you
want to enhance and feed the fears so
you want to keep giving you the stuff
that all the cities are falling apart or
whatever and
and it happens to it doesn't happen to
one group it happens to
the more entrenched you are and the more
involved you are
with the algorithms on on whatever
platform it polarizes you in both
directions and then you
because for me it's you've got people
like for
years now i think like sasha baron cohen
the comedian borat you know has been
very vocal in sounding an alarm about
this he's not the only one but
you know it's just like i didn't i was
like i think
he's in an interesting position because
of how
uh he kind of his entertainment has been
to
psychologically manipulate people and
expose
people's true colors right so he's
but but he's very outraged in how people
are being manipulated without them
knowing yeah but it's not something that
you know you okay it's not that fun to
listen to somebody get that upset
and it's not that and it but then you
the documentary is
really well made it makes it a little
more palatable to to explore the ideas
but then it's kind of like watching
super size me and then saying
are you really never gonna eat
mcdonald's or fast food again
not really you know it's like it's so
entrenched and like
i don't we're not on facebook and the
way that we're on instagram and twitter
is like it's professionally and it's
it's different but like
so i feel like we've been on the
outskirts of a lot of this
and i just haven't understood the extent
to which
people are will only get
information that works for them and so
it's like that whenever you think
how could anybody believe
fill in the blank but i mean all this
information i'm reading
it's a foregone conclusion that x y and
z
and then it's like well because someone
else is getting complete
a completely different set of
information and it's scary
and but i don't think you're getting at
this being the achilles
right well i i am in one sense
because you know if you think about it
you're going to say like is it
ego and i don't think there's a tie yeah
well
i guess what i'm getting getting at is
this is not
like this isn't unexpected at all right
so if you think about the history of
humankind like we actually
have not adapted to believe truth right
in fact it's more strategic
from a natural selection evolutionary
standpoint
to believe things that aren't true in
fact uh
i think it was in sapiens uh
where he explains this really really
well where he just talks about like
as a matter of fact our ability to
believe things that aren't true that are
kind of
outside of the natural realm to kind of
hold on to a thought an ideological idea
is what enabled us to kind of come
together and do things but we're always
coming together at the expense
of another group of people so take it
like if you just take it like two
examples like you've got two villages
it's more advantageous for my village to
believe things that are not true about
your village
and also to believe things that are not
true about my own village because if
i'm trying to pass my jeans on and my
village wants to win versus your village
it's like i'm going to make things up
about your your village
like they're nasty they they believe
crazy stuff
they deserve to die and if i can believe
that then i can go
and i can feel justified in killing them
right and we're kind of seeing
a version of that we're not necessarily
i mean people are killing each other
but the more common thing is people are
just completely
writing off a whole group of people and
thinking certain things about them
having all kinds of assumptions about
them
and then feeding themselves with all
this information that makes them feel
better about being able to believe that
and kind of perpetuates it
so to if it gets back to this idea of
like
our technology i mean you could say
things like well
we develop the ability to literally
destroy our planet like if you want like
nuclear weapons right before we
developed
a respect and an empathy for one another
and
where we wouldn't be the enemy because
what did we do we developed a nuclear
weapon
and then we used it on another on a
population
we dropped two atom bombs
on two cities like within
a couple of you know decades after
i can't remember i don't know the
timeline not many years after developing
the technology it was
used and it's a wonder that it hasn't
been used again
um but i mean i listen i go back to
and you've got these really smart
computer
dudes who just like created these
algorithms in order to
engage people and connect people
socially
and it but it has all these they're not
they're not i mean you see the hearings
you see mark zuckerberg at the hearings
it's like
deer in headlights people come into
grips with
and i have i haven't read all the
articles about it but you know you
jack dorsey or whatever the the the the
head of twitter is and like the journey
that he's gone on like
finding yourself in this position of
you've created this thing which
may very well be a monster that it's
like that's not what you set out to
create
and it's but now you have to you have
that amount of power like it's like
it's scary yeah and it it and it is
um it's comfortable i think i think it's
a huge piece of it like yeah
it's exactly what i'm saying like the
technological advance
to be able to connect the world in this
way that seems so promising
but yet you're connecting people who
haven't morally evolved
we haven't morally evolved to a place
where we can actually
be more interested in the interest of
another person than ourselves like we
just we haven't gotten there yet
um and you know you two so
so selfishness and
they're i i'm trying to pinpoint that
achilles heel and just
trying to to me at some point what
you're saying i'm just saying
ultimately it's the pacing of the
technology getting ahead of the moral
evolution because i do think that there
is a place
that you know i think the natural
seems to me that the natural sort of
progression of humanity even though
especially come from like the background
that we come from
like an evangelical christian mindset is
is what we were raised in
and the the narrative is that things are
getting worse
it's one of the reasons that evangelical
christians tend to be
conservative because there is this idea
that things used to be good and the
world is in decay
and things are moving towards the end
times up until the point where jesus
will come back so things are getting
worse as you go whereas a progressive
mentality is
actually things used to be pretty shitty
like people got killed
all the time by each other and by
disease and
you know as time has gone on we've
actually gotten things
have gotten better for more people
stephen pinker has a great book about
this
that kind of it kind of explains how
things have actually gotten better just
by the raw numbers things are moving
towards more connectivity and more
equality for more people
right i mean
it's it's tough to get there but i just
think that
uh we haven't
gotten to a place where we can really
put ourselves
in someone else's shoes and now it would
be one thing if we got to a place where
it's like yes we were super empathetic
and we were cooperative
and we saw ourselves as one human race
we saw ourselves as stewards
of the planet and then we developed the
ability to be interconnected like the
things that we could do would be amazing
but we haven't gotten there yet i mean
think about this it's 20 20.
we've known the science behind global
warming
for decades now right uh
it's relatively simple science it's that
very small changes in the concentration
of carbon dioxide and
methane in the atmosphere and other
greenhouse gases leads to
more retained heat it's pretty it's
complex
but the overall principle is pretty
simple right and
lots of people sounding the alarm seeing
all kinds of
the beginnings of the of like more and
more evidence building
in this direction everyone who looks at
this is seeing more and more evidence
but yet there's a whole group of people
including the president who are saying
that this is not happening
right they're saying this is not
happening and in fact
this is the government's attempt to
overreach and control
and all this stuff and the amount of
misinformation around this issue that
could be
the only thing that matters a hundred
years from now it could be
i hope it isn't and it's hard not to see
that as just trying to protect
the people entrenched on that side
trying to protect something that they
want to hold on to dearly that benefits
them
personally well and and and
and maybe that's an oversimplification
by being on the other side of the issue
well
here's what i'll say but it's it so to
me it doesn't
like you don't even have to get into the
science of global warming
to like be pro-green technology i mean
like if you just think about it
logically if you think about
we currently are based in a system that
is taking advantage of a finite resource
that took
millions of years to develop and we're
depleting it in a couple of generations
like it doesn't matter even if global
warming wasn't a thing
transitioning to primarily renewable
energy
would be a no freaking brainer and we'd
be like who knows what's going to happen
maybe we're going to get
an asteroid someday and this and we're
going to go into a nuclear winter for a
few years and we're going to need to
burn this coal and
need to burn this oil we need to hold on
to it there's
there's the only thing that you can
point to and again
i'm this is somebody i was evangelical
christian
conservative for most of my adult life
or a good portion of my adult life and
so when i thought about the issue of
global warming the only thing i thought
about was
i'm not supposed to believe that that's
real because it's not consistent with my
ideology and my platform i i can't
believe that that's real because
that's some sort of conspiracy that's
just designed for the government to take
control of everyone
and so did i ever stop and think but
like so in other words
i was allergic to actually investigating
it and looking into it i was allergic to
any sort of viewpoint that might be
the opposite of what i thought at the
time you're saying you had a blind
allegiance i
i think the thing that's difficult
is that i mean if you look at the
the covid experience in the united
states and you
you look at how how poorly
you look at the numbers compared to the
rest of the world and
there's few that there's a few countries
that rival the number of deaths that
we've had it's just
i mean there's it's
it's not as simple as we
as americans just aren't haven't been
willing to
place the the need the greater good
above our own current needs i mean it's
personal needs
or or wants or desires for
freedom or ideology or whatever the
reasons are there's
that is true for sadly a bunch of people
i think
but then there's also these people who
are like their
their livelihood depends on it when you
think about like a dependence on fossil
fuels yeah you got all
you've got all of this money the most
profitable business in the history of
our planet
but then the fossil fuel industry but
then you've got by far but then you've
got people
like working-class people who
their livelihoods depend on this
industry
you know so it's and so you've got
you've got to address that
that has to be part of what's addressed
in order to
to get through to get through kovid to
to stem the tide of
of uh climate change is that
there are people who are in dire straits
or will be
as as a result of the necessary changes
to
to to stem the tide of our own
decimation
and a lot of people it's just like i got
to survive tomorrow
yeah so it's a very short-term mentality
for sure but it's sad when you zoom out
that it's really driven by
the ultra-rich
who are fueling who are fueled by and
fueling these industries
um when it comes to climate change
manipulating the conversation and
manipulating the information and making
it seem like
or if you look at this there's a debate
here right and i mean i
i think that's true a lot of the big
issues when you look at health care if
you look at like universal health care
and you're like what doesn't why
wouldn't anyone want
everyone to be able to get
treatment when they needed it you know
it's like well it's
it's just a lot more complicated than
that and that's that's a sad reality but
that doesn't
i'm not saying that it's not complicated
i'm saying it is but that doesn't change
the fact that
well at a certain point we have to we
have to
we have to band together to do the right
thing and and
unless we do it these things will never
change
that's what's so um
so sad is that it's gonna take all of us
right i mean it's because because the
the changes have to happen at such an
accelerated pace it's going to take
it's going to take a majority of us uh
you know
well unless democracy completely
collapses
at that point it and and in some senses
in america
that has has already happened and it has
been the case it's like
the people with money they're in control
and they're they're manipulating the
conversation they're more well a very
much higher influence in the
conversation so but
yeah i you know i like saw the thing
where uh the governor of california
gavin newsom was talking about okay he's
got this executive order where
you know we're gonna ban the sale of gas
powered cars by 20 to 35.
he didn't say he was going to ban
gas-powered cars period if you have one
you can still drive it
but the sale of new cars in 15 years
from now
and in just cars like
small because industrial like farm
vehicles
trucks and stuff like that it's 20 45
like so we're giving them 25 years to to
get on board
now predictably but still like sat
is so sad saddening to me is like the
response like
nine out of ten responses to this on
twitter
are this guy's crazy
this is incredibly crazy like
as so what we got is we've got a
situation where
i hope that they're wrong but the people
who know a lot more about this than i do
are telling me that i should be worried
about this right
that i should care about what's
happening this is what's happening on
earth
and this is what could happen on earth
if we don't do anything about this
and then somebody in a position of power
says all right well here's what i'm
going to do
and then he's just he's treated as an
idiot
so until
those those people are never going to go
away there's always going to be people
who are like
going to just you know not believe even
even you know 100 maybe 100 years from
now
when there's absolutely no doubt that
climate change happened and that
the humans were responsible for the vast
majority of this particular
portion of it in this point in history
uh
it'll just be like yeah there used to be
people who said it wasn't happening
yeah i mean they were wrong it's so
frustrating why can't we just have a
conversation about how
we're going to deal with it and not if
it exists or if we should deal with it
it's just it's maddening but the real
question is is a hundred years from now
has have things changed so drastically i
mean i
i'm an optimist as much as i might seem
like a pessimist
i do think that i'm like surely they're
going to figure this out like technology
like they're going to find some way to
get the carbon out of the air we're
going to transition to green technology
we're going to look back and be like
yeah there was this weird time in the
early 2000s where like
everybody was confused about what was
happening there's all this
misinformation there was this weird
thing happening with social media
yeah people were confused and nobody
knew what was going on but we got
through it
yeah it's just like we have a vaccine
for kovid
everyone's going to forget about the
whole mask fiasco
you know i don't want to have to wear a
mask because i just wait for the vaccine
you know it's like uh and i feel like
we're in a
we're in a position we're in a
privileged position
you know because we're well off
uh we're we're privileged and it look at
it from
from almost any angle and i just yeah
you know there's
to me honestly i feel like
you know just maybe this just exposes me
for like a lot of critique but i
feel like it i'm in a bit of a more
objective place
because you know i i'm not going
paycheck to paycheck
i'm not my livelihood is not directly
tied to
a certain ideology i mean us talking
like this
we may lose fans but it's it's not i'm
not we're not being threatened
i don't understand why and i think
that's why celebrities like movie stars
and people like
who when they when they speak out people
will say things like
just shut up and be a basketball player
or just shut up and be an actor
you know you know
you get to a point of privilege where
you can say
i have so much money i think these
superstars like a
leonardo dicaprio or a george clooney
they have so much money
that they they they can actually say
you know what i can actually do the
right thing i can afford to do the right
thing
and i don't think that's why they're
doing it but it's like to me
you can listen to those people who are
saying these things because
uh they're they're trying to do the
right thing that's the skin they have in
the game and i feel for the
i feel for the people who you know
it's hard for them to do the right thing
because it directly affects their
their livelihood like are they going to
get another paycheck or something like
that
and then you got the people who who have
all the money who aren't doing the right
thing who are
who are only thinking about themselves
i think there's a stark contrast there
and so well and there's also
you know and we saw this when we told
our deconstruction story it's like
you know we have one perspective on the
world that we came from in the world
that we're in right now well people who
are still in that world are like well
you guys are in a cult
now you know what i'm saying like you
guys you guys had it right you were in
the right place you had the right
mentality the right ideology and then
for personal reasons for person you know
because you wanted fame and fortune and
you knew that you had to adopt these
this liberal mindset and be vocal about
it in order to receive
the blessings of the masses and of
hollywood you had to do these things
so you guys are just following a script
a very predictable script
and that's the only reason that you talk
about this stuff in the way that you
talk about it now
and for somebody who believes that which
i would have believed that
at this one point in my life i can't say
anything
that's going to be convincing there's
nothing that i can say if if i can say
well
the reason that i left
the place that i was in um
what i was actually concerned about
truth and i feel like i
followed the evidence and the data to a
different place
now am i some freaking robot who only
makes decisions based on data no
i'm still part of the human race i'm
still susceptible to
the group mentality i'm still
susceptible to buying into ideology
i'm just still susceptible to buying
into
a whole platform yes i'm still
susceptible to
feeling like i have to say something
just to make people
feel like i believe the right thing it's
like yes i'm still a human
but because i came from a place that was
the ideology was very strong and it was
very developed
and the thinking was very systematic and
there was a herd mentality
uh i became uncomfortable with that and
i was like i kind of feel like i'm being
told to believe
a certain set of things because this is
what makes it all seem to fit together
and makes us all feel connected
but like i actually feel like some of
it's not true guys
and what in my and what i ended up doing
is i ended up getting out of that
and so which is why i now worship bill
gates
so but so jesse and i are the guy who
can yeah we're really sensitive to this
because
i don't want i'm i'm really this is why
i'm this is why politically i'm an
independent i'm not a registered
republican or registered democrat
uh and i don't i'm not saying that it's
like a point of pride but for me it's
like a it's a principle
because i'm like i don't want to
jump out of this camp and then just go
that's that's basically supported
and sort of uh bolstered by ideological
thinking and then just moving to this
other camp
um and again this may sound like oh well
you've what you've done that
but i tr i try to be as critical
of it as i can but i mean just when it
comes to this like the issue of
uh climate change which again i think is
sort of supersedes
it might not but if what they're saying
is true
then it does supersede everything else
and it is sort of the problem of our
generation
and the biggest threat humanity's ever
faced and the one thing that we
actually need to agree on and tackle
uh i kind of i'm in the boat that's like
all right what if it's not as bad as
they're saying what if it doesn't happen
like what does coming together and
working together on a problem
like how does humanity coming together
how is it bad i don't it doesn't make
sense to me like i'm not
threatened by unity in the way that i
used to be like the idea of like
our borders not being that important and
coming together this whole idea of like
one world
like i actually i'm encouraged by that
now because i think it's the only hope
for humanity i don't think that this
let's let's separate let's build the
walls
let's differentiate ourselves like we've
already seen
what that does that results in death and
destruction
yeah i think the achilles heel is
it's it's that deeply rooted
drive for self-preservation first i mean
ironically for
survival on an on an individual yeah
which i.e selfishness well and it's and
it's
it's it's tricky because it's not just
individual it's it's individual
and then it's group but it's very
difficult
to for the empathy to spread outside of
the in group the in-group and the
out-group mentality
and now that we're it's funny we we the
i
the irony of becoming super connected
through technology
but not having developed the brain and
i'm not saying this is
not how much stupidity or intelligence
i'm just saying our brains
have not developed to a place yet where
we
actually can get out of the in-group and
out-group thinking
all of us and the technology has instead
of connecting us is enhance the
in-grouping and out-grouping in a way
that like
we're more divided now than we ever were
like people like i i saw i saw
a guy tweet
uh this is i saw this he was a liberal
dude
um progressive dude and he was talking
about how his trump supporting
neighbor was locked out of his house and
it was raining
and he was like he tweeted like my trump
supporting neighbor is locked my maggot
neighbor is locked out of his house
what should i do oh god and like people
started like saying well you should just
let him shoot out during the rain and
all this stuff
and i was just like how is this a
question
i don't care honestly i don't care who
the dude supports
i mean i may care and i may disagree but
like if
my neighbor is locked out of his house
and needs me to help him needs me to
call somebody
that's that's what we should be doing
you know what i'm saying like
how we've lost the ability i'm not gonna
help you because i disagree with you
politically like i'm not gonna help you
with a basic need
like what the hell has happened to
people how is this even a question and
how is it that you can ask this question
on twitter and people
i mean some people are like you should
help the dude it doesn't i mean
okay yeah he you disagree with him
politically you may stand against every
value that he has
but he's a human in need help him
you know i and i i see that and i'm just
like
there is not a lot of hope i just
there's not a lot of hope
and that it it to me it just seems like
common decency and i just don't get it
i don't understand you know i've got
lots of people in my life
who are going to vote for trump and i
got lots of people in my life who are
going to vote for biden
and i can and i can have
intelligent you know respectable
debate with them and i may like really
really
really have strong opinions about this
and it may even get heated at times
but the moment that they get hurt or
they need something basic my connection
to them as a fellow human
supersedes my political ideology and i
just
and if we can if it doesn't we are
doomed
doomed i thought you said this was going
to get heavy
[Laughter]
all right well at least we just solved
it um
it's my wreck i'm i'm going to try to
i'm going to try to turn it back to
something light
uh i'm gonna recommend i'm gonna go back
to our board game episode okay good
i i talked about the board game that i
had ordered called parks
so wreck baby wreck baby one two three
four this is my recommendation uh you
can get it at target barnes and noble
uh amazon uh parks by key master games
um i had ordered through their kicks uh
their kickstarter campaign
they raised like over half a million
dollars to do the expansion pack because
this game is so popular
um and you know what it it
they're not it's not here yet because i
didn't order through the places i just
said
it was delay my game arriving was
delayed until the expansion pack was
produced as well
because i joined as like a higher level
kickstarter because i was just
i was excited to get to play a game
about national parks to hopefully get my
kids into games and national parks at
the same time
the artwork is is really great
the workmanship on these things is
really great i've already talked this up
but then in the mail i i got the game
before the expansion pack is out and
inside there was a note
from the people at key master games they
had heard
our conversation about they sent you an
early copy yeah
well they sent because the game itself
is available
other places and they had that in stock
they went ahead and sent that to me
along with like a
personalized note about having heard our
conversation and
like getting more kids and families into
playing games
it was a very sweet i keep the i keep
the letter from them
in the game which they didn't i paid for
it they didn't give it to me for free
i didn't want it for free uh and this is
not
again this is not a sponsor uh and i'm
still waiting on the expansion pack but
uh we started to play it
it was a little it was it it was a bit
of a learning curve having not played a
lot of games
and then like the family they just they
didn't have a lot of patience
chris was like you know what why don't
you like
why don't we put a pen in this maybe you
can watch a video that like
shows how to play the game instead of
you trying to figure it out and teach us
at the same time i was like you know
what that's fair
so we like yeah we reconvened i did some
research i watched some playthroughs and
then i
i was i knew how to play the game hot
tip if you're going to teach your family
how to play a game you should already
know how to play it
because it could be maybe just show them
the video very slow and frustrating well
i watched like an
hour and a half play through okay i'm
now that guy
i watch i watch board games being played
for an hour and a half on youtube
that's what it took and then we played
it
and then last night after dinner
lily and lincoln lando were like let's
play parks again
like the two of them hardly ever want to
do the same thing
and like we played again last night very
very good game
um well worth the 50 bucks that you have
to pay to get the
what is the object um
to to visit parks
and have an um just an amazing
experience with lots of great memories
basically they have the most number of
points at the end of the game by collect
by by visiting the most parks and
there's like resources involved
how do you kind of like sabotage other
players uh you can block them out of
getting to places
on the hike that they need to get to in
order to
reach their personal goals in order to
get there to
rank up their points isn't it funny if
the object of the game was just for
everybody to get what they wanted
and everybody to have a good time you
wouldn't enjoy it
i mean i'm just saying yeah the reason
i'm the reason i ask the question
is because it it goes back to the
conversation we just had
there's something in trent there's
something inside of us
that we well because we don't want
everybody to win
we don't want everybody to win only one
person can win the game
so and you have to yeah you're trying to
do everything strategically in order to
yeah but that appeals to us to block
people out that appeals to something
that is so deeply in other words what
i'm saying is and i'm not trying to be
the downer again i know you try to bring
it up but it may be
that that mentality is so deeply
ingrained in us
that there is no scenario where all of a
sudden we become
nine ten billion people on a planet and
it's just a utopia
like maybe it's not possible maybe
there's always got to be a winner and
always got to be a loser is something in
our brains that we are never going to be
able to let go of
unless there's some sort of deep
deprogramming and so
we're going to build the population up
and then we're going to decimate one
another and then it's going to start
again and it's always going to happen
like well i'll say
because of the the artwork is so
beautiful
and because it's about experiencing
parks it
it feels it feels better better and like
so when i did you know
i enjoyed working my brain in order to
strategize to get as many points as
possible
but if i lose i still find myself being
pretty happy
maybe the key lincoln doesn't though
i'll tell you lincoln is competitive
okay yeah good for him here's the thing
i'm very
competitive as we've established but
yeah i still want everybody i want the
world to work together i want us to get
to utopia
but i just kind of feel like
there's not enough people on board and
that's what i was trying to say about
celebrities it's like in a lot of ways i
feel like
i've gotten what i want out of life it's
like the bill gates of it all he's
gotten what he
wants out of life and how he's devoted
his time his energy and his
massive resources to making a positive
difference it's like i'm not going to
you mean controlling
you mean i'm not going to say that he
designed and manipulated
does does he have completely pure
motives does anybody but like
he's one of them he's in a position that
makes him
more true i deem him more trustworthy
and i feel like
honestly from my own experience i think
it was mostly melinda
okay i think she was the one who was
like all right i think bill
yeah we're the richest people on earth
yeah let's do some good
and i think she talked him into it
that's kind of well i i i take it all
back i apply it to melinda
it is the bill and melinda gates
foundation after all
um
i was going to make a statement about
ulterior motives and like figuring all
that out but i don't want to go back
there
just enjoy parks the board game
enjoy parks and just enjoy parks in
general if you can get get into it oh
yeah do that
hashtag your biscuits to watch more ear
biscuits click on the playlist on the
right to watch the previous episode of
your biscuits click on the playlist to
the left and don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best